[Music]
first night of live shows that AGT was
filled with amazing talent but what
really took center stage Mel B's dating
life did you know that your dating life
would be front and center tonight no you
have fun up there without we've got to
it's a great show we all got a great
panel for a great contestants yeah we're
gonna look amazing amazing with you I
mean is this worth single Mel is rocking
these days I'm in the body shop I've
kind of dived into a bit of you know
see-through stuff before but today I was
feeling the blue superhero vibes it's
good to change if I'm like a girly girl
I like to dress up also amazing
ten-year-old contestant Angelica Hale
[Music]
for performance made Mel a bit emotional
people's lives can change during the
show and they're put in their heart and
soul out there and it's live so anything
can happen so you have to feel for them
and I feel the energy and the
nervousness and I just have my fingers
crossed and today was a good day
and you also mention you had a
connection to that song what was that
why the emotions - clarity about telling
you know I'll do with sex
no it's really
[Music]